so
[Music]
coming up braden meets max and harvey
who want us to save our parents money
and our local libraries by picking up a
book
with families worried about costly
activities this summer holidays we're
being encouraged to get to our libraries
and get reading
[Music]
also coming up you get your shout on
football boots why they labeled for boys
in some shops but not for girls
[Music]
welcome to fyi your weekly news show
that's jam-packed full of info our
mission is to get on top of the news and
have a say on the issues that affect us
the big story over the last few days
have been the record-breaking
temperatures of course over 40 degrees
in some places yeah well firemen have
been reporting about fires across
england and wales and a lot of them have
been caused by grass setting on fire
like this one that damaged homes in
london
some rail tracks buckled and roads
melted causing travel problems too
crazy
scientists say we should expect to see a
lot more extreme weather like this
because of climate change for more
details on the causes or what's being
done about it check out our i don't get
it explainer just head to sky kids on
demand or via our webpage at first.news
fyi
some people and animals did have fun in
the sun though
animals at various zoos including this
wildlife park were treated to frozen
smoothies of veg and fruit
and who says private pools are only for
the rich the diy dad of the year award
goes to this one who looked up how to
build a swimming pool online and built
one for a fraction of the cost
[Applause]
we'll be talking to an expert later on
how to stay safe while swimming and the
race to be the next prime minister is
also heating up one of these two
politicians will be our next leader
so the whole process to replace boris
johnson who resigned is a bit like
britain's got talent
loads of conservative party politicians
put their names forward they had to take
part in tv interviews and debates to
prove they've got what it takes and then
one by one they were knocked out of the
race through rounds of voting by
conservative party politicians
the two finalists are the former
chancellor rishi sunak he was in charge
of the money the government spends
and liz truss who is the foreign
secretary dealing with big issues abroad
like the ukraine war now members of the
conservative party will have to choose
between them with the results announced
in september
right so we've been in the hump for some
fake news we've each got a story but for
a bit of fun can you tell which one's
fake
[Music]
so according to some newspapers this cat
which was rescued from a house fire in
london has become the first pet to be
saved from suffocating in the smoke
by using a special oxygen mask for
animals
that does sound so fake but what do you
make of my story
this video went viral of a newly
launched sky hotel called the sky crows
it looks amazing i bet prices for a
rumor sky high though
one of these stories is fake but which
one we'll reveal all later
[Music]
with the price of petrol electricity gas
and food going up it's understandable
that people are worried about the cost
of our days out during the summer
holidays so to help out our parents
would you consider reading a book well
the annual summer reading challenge is a
project that tries to get us all to read
more and this year they want us to
support our local libraries and our
parents wallets and it's got the backing
of singers max and harvey and they met
up with braden
[Music]
every year thousands of you guys take
part in this summer reading challenge
and this year's theme is science and
innovation so what better place to find
out all about it than the science and
industry museum here in manchester and
i'm joined by two singers max and harvey
who is supporting and back in the
campaign hello hello so what made you
want to you know get behind this
campaign it's really important for
people to just keep active whether it's
mentally or physically and i think you
know reading is a massive part of that
and also loads of families will be
looking for free activities to do over
the summer and this one's a great one
for it isn't it because it's really
accessible and anyone can do it because
all you have to do is just go down to
your local library right yeah you can
either go down to your local library or
hop online and the goal is to get people
to read six things over six weeks
last year for the first time in 10 years
the annual library survey estimated that
libraries in the uk have increased by
175
but since 2010 around 600 public
libraries have shut down because of less
government funding
so summer reading challenge is
encouraging us all to get to our local
libraries so what do you guys like to
read what's your favorite book i would
say wonder by rj palacio which is a
story about a boy who goes to school but
he looks a little bit different from
everyone else it's a really really cool
story yeah i like the hunger games
because you know i remember reading that
in school and after school and it's just
my favorite book now obviously we know
that you guys are singers now did
reading maybe help you get into music
we're also presenters on the side as
well i think our amount of reading that
we did as kids really broadened our
vocabulary and just being able to speak
confidently and knowing what to say next
is a very useful skill that you can gain
from reading but what i will say is
having a big sort of knowledge of the
english language and how it all works
and stuff is very useful for writing
lyrics but you can use different words
and songs that's very useful because
then it makes it more unique so we know
that this year's theme for the reading
challenge is science and innovation now
do you guys like science did you like it
when you was at school
max maybe not so much of a fan but i was
obsessed i liked science i might have
messed around a little bit too much so
there's your answer for that maybe max
wasn't allowed to use the bunsen burners
unsupervised but i certainly loved
especially chemistry and biology well
thank you so much for your time guys and
thank you you know for coming
well fourteen-year-old theo bihi doesn't
just love reading books he's got his own
book published
johnny recruit is based on a real-life
world war two story
now that's an inspiration to have a go
at producing your own book
fyi is the new show where you get your
shout on the issues that affect us
summer from bolton got in touch with us
she thinks it's unfair that every time
she goes shopping for football boots at
sports direct they're always labeled as
being for boys
with the female england team doing so
well in the euros she thinks it's about
time that sport outlets stop branding
football boots just for boys
hi fyi i'm summer and i love playing
football i love playing football because
i like scoring goals and being part of
my teams i train for three different
teams both boys and girls and train four
times a week
i went into sports direct to buy some
new football boots with my mum and i
noticed that all the labels said they
were for boys
and there was no girls boots in the shop
at all it made me feel very angry
because lots of girls play football too
it's not fair why are they boys boots
it doesn't matter what color i make we
are girl's feet are no different to boys
feet feet are just feet aren't they
i want sports direct in other sports
shops to change their labels to unisex
or just kids boots thanks for showing my
video fyi bye
so we've invited sports direct to talk
to us but so far they haven't responded
in a statement for summer's local
newspaper they've insisted that they
make sure all sport and fitness is
accessible to all we've got some fy
viewers joining us now to see if they
agree with summer hi everyone hey
so you've seen summer's story what do
you think do you think that football
boots should be unisex i feel like they
should be unisex or just for everybody
instead of just
cut down for one gender yeah personally
i think they should be because at a
young age
they're obviously your feet are
essentially the same i believe feet are
practically feet and
it's all really a matter of sizing with
football shoes it's also setting an
example for younger kids if they go if
they like football and they go and they
see oh it just says boys so i guess i
can't do it do you think that there are
any other sports where there isn't
enough equipment for girls i think um in
nearly every sports shop i think all the
opportunities and all the advertisement
for girls sports is a lot less and i
think this should be addressed quite
quickly i think if
people just
stop labeling everything you can like it
doesn't have to be specifically boys
girls it's just there for
just to set boundaries between what
girls and boys can't do thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you might have heard that more children
have died swimming in open water during
the hot weather
but amongst the awful headlines some
good news this is finley and he's
receiving an award from the royal
national lifeboat institute
by reading about the float to live
technique finley knew exactly what to do
when he saw a young boy drowning whilst
on holiday in cornwall he got him to
float like a starfish until help arrived
i put my arms underneath
him and dropping him back to shore and
then the like lifeguard guy came over to
check if he was all right we've got a
hold of gabby batchelor from the rnli hi
gabby hi here so the starfish formation
can really save your life but what else
can we do to stay safe in the water this
summer
so to stay safe this summer we are
asking everyone if you go to the coast
please head to a life-guarded beach and
swim between the red and yellow flags
this is because this is the safest place
to swim it's where there's lifeguards on
patrol and also they will watch out for
you remember to also stay together with
your friends and your family and take
time to learn about the risks such as
tides which could catch you out and
those strong currents please don't jump
from groins or anywhere where you don't
know what the depth is of the water
beneath you and always call 999 in a
coastal emergency so if we do want to go
swimming are there any open waters that
we shouldn't be going in
so it's always best to head to a venue
or a life-guarded beach preferably and
there'll always be signs which will tell
you whether or not it's safe to swim so
please do not swim in quarries or
reservoirs because you don't know what's
beneath and it can be really cold colder
than you think and there is a real risk
of cold water shock well that's really
great advice i mean especially during
this heat wave thank you gabby thank you
next we have another story from an fyi
viewer emma from wrexham in north wales
has to take care of her deaf parents she
wanted to share her world with us emma
hopes that more of us will give sign
language a go to make her life and the
lives of all deaf people much easier
it's really funny
[Music]
do you know what's happening
the purple dog
lives in space
i think
yeah
[Music]
i think people think negatively when it
comes to thinking about deaf people
but i think it's quite amazing to have
deaf parents because you get to
not only experience the world from
the hearing side but also from the deaf
side
please i care for my parents because
they're both profoundly deaf which means
that they can't
hear anything around them
put these
spinach there's an orange
say if we need some shopping or if i
need to go pick up prescriptions for her
then i'm often the one that has to do it
she does help me
and the things that she does is if i get
letters through the post she makes phone
calls for me appointments say the
doctors or the hospital
friday friday 11th and friday the 11th
it does just get quite tiring do you
want me to change yeah having that
responsibility it just takes up a lot of
my energy i think and
it doesn't always leave me with
time
to do things that i want to do
yes i do rely on emma
because i think she needs to be doing
her own things she's a girl and she
should be doing things herself
she shouldn't be involved with helping
me
give it something put it by mum she'll
give it to me after one thing that is
quite cool about having deaf parents is
being able to communicate in a whole
different language that not many people
know and i think it just makes it so
special
making deafness and sign language more
inclusive in our everyday lives i think
it could really impact deaf people
everywhere
positively
for more details of how you can report
on your own story like emma or have your
say on fyi head to our webpage
[Music]
so did you guess which was the fake
story here we go
so this cat was the first pet to be
rescued from a fire using a new oxygen
mask just for animals it's a fact it
means our pets can be safe from the
dangers of smoke as they are rescued
they come in three sizes and can also be
used on dogs as well as rabbits snakes
and mice
that means this flying hotel is fake
shame it looks cool the realistic video
fooled three million people on social
media
[Music]
for more details on how to spot fake
news check out our cool i don't get it
explainers on the fyi webpage and that's
all the info we've got for you except
for news about this amazing cyclist
[Music]
[Applause]
rupert from leicestershire is seven
years old and has become one of the
youngest cyclists to ride from london to
paris under the watchful eye of his
family
he did it to raise money for a charity
that supported him after his dad tom
died
rupert from leicestershire raised more
than 11 000 pounds for the children's
bereavement center amazing see you next
time
[Music]